well hello everyone
and welcome to the second installment of
the webinar series doing chinese history
in a new era
this series is organized by denise ho at
yale university and myself
emily baum at uc irvine and it began
last summer in response to the
persistent
and in some ways unprecedented
challenges that have been facing
researchers and scholars
in the chinese studies field so the
series has been generously sponsored by
the council on east asian studies at
yale university
and the long us china institute at uc
irvine
we are also very grateful to our long
list of
co-sponsors and if you'll just bear with
me for a second i'm going to read
through them really quickly
harvard university's fairbanks center
the center for east asian studies at
stanford university
the project on china's global sharp
power
at the hoover institution at stanford
the center for asian research at york
university
the department of history at simon
fraser university
the institute of asian research at the
university of british columbia
the east asian studies program at johns
hopkins university
the east asian studies program at uc
santa cruz
the global china center at hong kong
university of science and technology
and the hong kong institute for the
humanities and social sciences
at the university of hong kong so in
this session we will be focusing on the
subject
of pivoting to a new research topic
many of us myself included have had to
dramatically change or rethink the
content and scope of our research
in the face of challenges imposed by
kobit 19
archival closures or simply increasing
restrictions
on travel and free speech to address
some of these issues we have invited
four speakers who are either completing
or who have recently completed a thesis
or dissertation
and who have had to adapt their topics
because of changing research conditions
they are going to speak about their
experiences and hopefully offer some
advice and guidance for those of us who
are facing similar circumstances
so each presenter will speak for
approximately 10 minutes and at the end
of the session we will reconvene for a
moderated q a
if you have a question at any point and
you don't necessarily have to wait
for the q a session but please feel free
to ask your question
using the q a button at the bottom of
your screen
in total this webinar should last for
approximately 75 minutes just to give
you a heads up
and it will be recorded in case you
can't stay until the end
we will send out a link to the youtube
video in a follow-up email to all
registered participants
so let us go ahead and get started
speaking first will be michael collins
michael
is a researcher focusing on china's
global governance initiatives
he was a research associate at the
council on foreign relations and before
that
he received his m.a in chinese history
from peking university's yunjin academy
so i will turn it over to you now
michael thanks so much
let me share my screen
great so um i guess the the theme of my
presentation
is researching chinese history
flexibility and
creativity so um
to start my original idea was uh or i
i began researching on my master thesis
in the fall
of 2018 uh at the time i was living on
peking university's campus
as part of the yen ching academy program
i originally intended for my thesis to
focus on
chinese anarchists at the turn of the
20th century
i wanted to show that rather than
passively receiving
anarchism from western sources whether
it was in paris or japan
chinese anarchists were playing a very
active role
and even leading the
east asian anarchist movement that was
occurring at this period
to do this i wanted to map out chinese
anarchist networks
to demonstrate their centrality to other
east and southeast asian anarchist
movements
particularly in korea and vietnam
and i was really inspired to do this by
a few different sources but particularly
by
a book by rf derlick and ming ke chan
that focused on shanghai's labor
university
which had an abundance of anarchists not
just from asia but from all over the
globe who were
working together to try and think about
how to give both theoretical
and practical teaching to um anarchists
a growing cohort of anarchists
in china to do this research i was
planning on using archives at pku and
fudon
as well as some libraries in the us and
the uk
i also expected to be able to travel
particularly to northeast provinces of
china where there was
a great number of archives that were
open to
um look at cooperation between north
korean anarchists
and american or in chinese anarchists
um so pretty quickly on in the research
process i
encountered um both bureaucratic
hurdles which i expected but also
political hurdles
that prevented me from accessing
archives
archives which had previously given me
agreements to
access certain materials came up with
reasons why i could no longer see them
and reasons that my classmates were not
facing
and heightened political sensitivities
around chinese anarchists especially as
kind of some
big uh historical anniversaries were
coming up in china
uh really tightened the access to
archives
even at pku which was surprising given
my
affiliation and then um once kovid
became um an issue in china and then
globally
and as u.s china ties really soured and
fell out
um i i my ability to access any
archives in china were pretty closed as
i relocated to the us
and so as i was um
kind of reformulating my plan
i took a moment to kind of mourn the
loss of the topic
and once i had kind of picked myself up
and gotten back in the race
i discussed with my thesis advisor
what uh would be feasible and he really
encouraged me to kind of
not give up on the topic but just widen
the aperture of what i was studying
and to return to my original literature
review to see if i could find
questions that would answer the same
question
give answers that i was still interested
in but
um would have materials that i could get
access to
easily and in a timely manner i also
assessed what was feasible given covid
restrictions and
at the time we really didn't know when
archives would reopen and so
i just kind of assumed that i would not
be able to go in person to any archives
um before uh my my thesis was due for
defense
um and so i really focused on archival
materials in the us and the uk
particularly resources that had
extensive digitized collections
um and uh also i reached out to
a number of scholars in the field people
whose books i was referencing
scholars i had met at conferences to
not only ask their advice but also to
see if they
had primary sources that i was looking
for
perhaps digitized on their own computer
or in their own records
and so um for the new topic
as i was doing this review a few weeks
into it i noticed a
relative lack of scholarly work on
chinese anarchists
in america particularly by historians of
america's labor movements and america's
anarchist movements
and i at the same time i noticed a
relative abundance
of primary source materials which told a
story
that i was intrigued to look into more
and really gave me the feeling that
there was a lot more out there that
i could uncover through the research so
um
i shifted gears a bit and i focused my
research topic on anarchist groups
started by chinese immigrants in america
and examined their participation in and
oftentimes their exclusion from early
20th century american labor
and anarchist movements and as a native
of the bay area
i was particularly focused on san
francisco which had a very vibrant
chinese immigrant community
and a very politically active immigrant
community
um for this research i am deeply deeply
indebted
to the work of the master archivist
himmark lai and um the berkeley
university libraries which have
fantastic collections a lot of which are
digitized
which really enabled me to to do this
research
and so um kind of over the year and a
half long process
of this research i've collected a number
of resources
and thought up of a few pieces of advice
that i hope are
very useful and i can kind of go in a
bit to
what i found the strengths of these
sources were
as well as kind of where they might be
lacking and so
for the first four that i have listed
under the resources
all of these were fantastic for
accessing
old publications newspapers anarchist
magazines
books that are no longer in circulation
or that are hard to come by
but especially with the first listed
source
i found that the search terms you have
to use
or the process for finding materials is
not the most straightforward
oftentimes materials are not categorized
by their name or by their subject
and so you really have to search far
afield to find what you're looking for
but once you find it they're usually
free to access free to download
um and are incredibly helpful and then
the last two are a bit more
um niche for people that are interested
in anarchists
movements whether they're in the u.s or
somewhere else but i found that the
online anarchist library and the kate
sharply library
were fantastic for kind of giving me
both a general picture of the landscape
but also for finding sources
that i didn't even know were out there
and they have dedicated teams that
curate the content
and are happy to answer questions um or
provide
advice for you um and then in terms of
advice
the main thing that i was told by my
advisor and i highly recommend was
read broadly um because i felt pressure
initially to really decide on a topic
and once i'd found it
to kind of dig down quickly and kind of
get to the work of writing
but when i stepped back i realized that
a lot of the books that i'd read whether
they were in undergrad or through the
course of my master's program
had tidbits of information or sources
that
i found useful once i went back to
rewrite and re-research
secondly think creatively and
re-evaluate
um and so for me i went from
going from a more i would say
descriptive
thesis topic to one which was more
focused on historiography
and trying to kind of fill in the
narrative
of both the american labor and anarchist
movements and
chinese immigrant stories in the us um
next i found it very helpful to look
broadly through anthologies and
appendices um because oftentimes
there's kind of hidden gems with with
within there that pointed me in the
right direction um
and then for the last the next two are
related but
contact scholars and librarians whether
it's over twitter linkedin
scholar net and lean on your peers in
wider network because
i found that by discussing my topic with
my cohort
they were often able to point me to a
bookstore in
manchester that had some of the sources
i was looking for
or at one point we were going through
somebody's garage
who had these boxes from a library that
they were um
that they used to curate which is since
closed and then finally i would say to
just
adjust expectations um i was
as i said very disappointed at the
outset
but once i kind of got through the
initial brief of the process of
the grief of the loss i was really happy
with the process
and was able to produce something that
i was very proud to defend so
thank you so much and i look forward to
your questions
great thank you so much michael um up
next
will be bill figueroa dr figueroa
completed his phd
at the university of pennsylvania and he
is currently a postdoctoral fellow
at the university of pennsylvania middle
east center
so bill go ahead
okay great well thank you for that
introduction i don't have a fancy
powerpoint but i'm just going to try to
um you know just share some of my
experiences
so the title of the workshop is you know
pivoting to a new research topic and
that's something i've had to do
a few times through the process of
finishing my phd
uh and i'm really glad to have the
opportunity to share my experiences with
you all so
you know thanks to emily and to everyone
else who uh you know put the work in to
put this together
um my dissertation ended up changing
substantially from how i originally
conceived it
in part due to problems in how i was
framing it and in part due to lack of
access to
archival sources even after i made
a lot of these changes i had to figure
finish the writing process
during the pandemic which also limited
my ability to track down new sources
uh or to revisit archives as new
questions came up but it also presented
some new opportunities so i'm going to
try to you know kind of take you through
that process going for uh
you know throughout this presentation um
after going through all that
um i do think i have some you know some
thoughts i can share about how to be
flexible with your topic
uh and in your approach to what sources
you can use and what kind of things you
can do with them
so when i started graduate school i i
had it in my mind that
i really wanted to study uh the history
of sino-iranian relations you know the
relationship between china
and iran i had been studying chinese
history and
you know chinese language as an
undergraduate for my master's
and during my phd i branched out to
middle eastern history and especially
the history of iran
and started studying persian um you know
my my
my goal was after looking at the the
research that had been done it was
really
clear to me that you know most of it had
been done by people either coming
you know primarily coming from the china
side and a bit coming from the iran side
and most people had only really looked
at sources from one language or another
and had otherwise been relying on
secondary sources or works in english
for everything else
um so you know as i was going through um
the the literature that had been done on
the subject i was it wasn't long before
i came across
anecdotes about the popularity of maoism
as a political orientation amongst
iranian student radicals in the 1960s
i was really intrigued by the idea of
iranian maoism which
seemed to demand an explanation and you
know has been largely overlooked
and at least according to me under
appreciated by historians of both
chinese and iranian history
so my original dissertation topic was on
just that it was on iranian maoism
it's history uh it's particular you know
the particular activities
of a specific maoist organization
salesman angela b
which was a branch of the main iranian
communist party the two-day party
uh and was run by dissident students in
europe uh salesman angelobi which means
the revolutionary organization as in
like the revolutionary faction of the
two-day party uh
was a major force amongst iranian
student politics in both europe and the
u.s in the 60s and 70s
and i wanted to write something like
like a thick history of their
organization
them as a social movement and their
impact on iranian history
as i could i charted out um you know and
part of the problem that i first
encountered was that this was
um a pretty brief moment in history you
know it was like mostly their influence
peaked from
the late 60s to the early 70s but i
still really wanted i was drawn to the
story
most intriguingly to me the group had
ties to the chinese government
and it traveled to china for you know
revolutionary and ideological training
they seem to play a part in china's
international propaganda efforts during
the cultural revolution
um and to me you know the story of these
like would-be revolutionaries was just
honestly really cool
it was the first thing that i discovered
that i was like you know this is
something that people don't know about
that i can write about that
excites me in a way you know it was
interesting it was new i didn't quite
fully understand it at first
um they had really cool um you know uh
uh
just sort of uh speeches and pamphlets
that they had put out just kind of like
really fascinating rhetoric and i wanted
to understand where it was coming from
how you had
this kind of fusion um or
cross-fertilization of interest
uh of islamists uh and radical uh
communists at the same time
so you know i was maybe a little bit
dazzled by the idea and
you know it was as a result i ended up
focusing pretty narrowly on this topic
alone at first
and that was probably my first mistake
um you know it's good to keep an open
mind
on the broader picture um so you know
once
once i came back down to earth about it
i ran into two problems right away
first was the problem of sources um i
couldn't access anything official about
this group
chinese archives you know as michael
mentioned during this period 2018 uh or
reportedly you know i didn't get a
chance to go and try but from what i'd
heard
they were not open to researchers in any
event i had been told by another uh by a
friend
uh who had uh had a personal interest
you know one of the people i uh
i ended up interviewing that they had
tried and failed a couple of years ago
to access
holdings related to sales money in
galaby at the foreign ministry archives
in beijing
so i didn't think i was going to be any
more successful than they were they
kind of had more of an even direct
connection than i did
the subject is also a little sensitive
in light of modern sino-iranian
relations and the official views of the
ccp
on its maoist past i have actually been
angrily berated by party members from a
chinese university before at a
conference over
just some objections they had to the way
i portrayed maoism as an ideology
so you know whenever you're working on
subjects like this it's it can be
difficult to access archives um
researching in iran
is similarly difficult um you know i i
think
probably people anyone who follows the
news understands that you know it's both
not feasible and not safe for americans
to do research on sensitive subjects in
iran
so i didn't really want to go down that
route the best bet for me
was to interview some of the
participants because they were still
around
some of them lived in europe in the
united states but that required
some networking and interviews in
persian and my language skills were just
they weren't quite up to the task just
yet you know i
i i could read but i wasn't quite ready
to conduct you know full-on interviews
and get the answers that i needed
secondly my primary advisor furuzei
khashani sabet
who i am really indebted for for both
the direction and the quality i think of
the
dissertation i produced in the end she
pointed out that iranian maoism was
at the end of the day a fascinating but
very narrow topic
it was a niche interest within a
subfield of iranian studies
mostly amongst historians of the iranian
left it would probably grab
you know attract some attention within
china studies but julia lovell hadn't
written her book yet
called global maoism so there wasn't as
much attention as that idea as there is
right now
um it also only covered as i said a
short period of time
and while i was excited about this idea
of a deep dive she encouraged me to
think bigger and broader
i needed to adjust my topic so that i'd
be able to attract the interest of a
wide variety of historians both within
and without my
my subfield in order to avoid
pigeonholing myself and to maximize my
chances on the job market i mean these
are serious things we have to think
about
um and you know being a historian of
both iran and china i really wanted to
avoid
um having to lean too hard one side and
to you know to
to uh to find myself in a position where
i wasn't
uh appealing to a broad enough uh
cross-section of people
to you know to be successful uh as
someone who's neither
entirely chinese or entirely middle east
studies when applying for jobs in the
china or middle east studies fields
so basically i reworked my project from
the ground up instead of focusing
narrowly on iranian maoism i decided to
carve out you know a bit of a larger
space for myself
i noted that all or nearly all studies
of cyber iranian history started around
1972
and focus on events after 1979. i
strongly suspected for my background
reading and from a few scraps of sources
i had come across
that there were substantial connections
in earlier periods as well
so i set out to write a survey of
sino-iranian relations from the
constitutional period
to the islamic revolution from 1905 to
1979
tracing different moments of both
official and unofficial sino-iranian
interactions um from the constitutional
period
to uh interactions between uh
nationalist china under chiang kai-shek
and uh the early nationalist uh
government of rezahan reza shah in iran
uh and then moving into sort of um cold
war
uh politics of the 1950s and 1960s
uh you know this was a lot broader and i
was able to keep iranian maoism as a
chapter
later on and it freed me up to find new
topics to focus on for the earlier
period
you know at first glance you would think
that this would actually make it harder
to study given the lack of sources but
it actually ended up giving me a lot
more to work with
once i realized that there were sources
i could use outside of archives
especially for those of you working on
the late 19th early 20th centuries
newspapers travelogues memoirs are an
incredible source
for day-to-day events you know that have
gone undocumented by historians
especially for those of you
who are looking to do something similar
um you know to sign to iranian relations
perhaps to look at another
uh less commonly explored uh aspect of
china's foreign policy or relations with
the rest of the world
i mean everyone's doing global history
right now right that's what we're all
we're all supposed to do
uh you know telegraphs allowed people
from all over the world during this time
to discuss and learn about foreign
affairs
and i found newspaper records of iranian
constitutionalists discussing china
chinese constitutionalists inspired by
persia iranian diplomats in shanghai
chinese merchants petitioning the
republican government for a trade
agreement with iran
iranian editorials on chiang kai-shek i
mean it was really just a lot of
different things i found
so i think my first tip is really just
keep an open mind about where you can
find your sources and what
constitutes a useful source to you it's
especially relevant for chinese history
because chinese newspapers are readily
available in digital form
there's a number of archives you can
access through a university subscription
if you're at a school
that supports research into chinese
history there's a good chance your
library has them
that's how i've always accessed them
through this you can find
chinese and english language newspapers
from the in published in china from the
late 19th century to the 20th century
for me that's been an absolute treasure
trove of sources about events that you
know otherwise i have no idea about
and they can be searched very easily in
digital form which makes things a lot
easier
this is also true about persian
newspapers although they're less readily
digitized
travelogues are also a great thing to
hunt down you have surprising
amounts of information buried in
travelogs about day-to-day activities of
people
in different places um some things i did
find in archives like pamphlets
propaganda posters um there's a lot of
material related to this stuff if you
are interested
at the international institute of social
history in amsterdam
um the hoover institute in california
where i got to do some research
although you do need to be able to read
persian for the most part they do have a
couple of things in english as well
when i was there i did make i made it a
habit of going for kind of brief
archival trips and digitizing as much as
i could on my own while i was there
and taking it home to read later and
it's a really good thing i did that
because shortly after i got back from
the archives and set to writing
the pandemic hit so you know at first
that made things a lot more difficult
because
or at least in theory because i couldn't
go to any other archives as i said as
questions came up
but in some ways it did kind of end up
being a blessing in disguise
other than the obvious fact that there
was literally nothing else to do except
work on my dissertation
which may have been a larger factor in
me actually completing it then i'd like
to admit
there was also the fact that you know
even more sources were being digitized
and made accessible due to the pandemic
i also turned to networking social media
i learned about this opportunity from
twitter
so you know that's actually been a
surprisingly good source of
not just information and networking but
also just
people who have a personal interest in
the things that you're studying who
might be able to supply you with
surprising sources
also just reaching out to scholars i met
at virtual conferences or who seemed
like they would be interested in my work
virtual conferences made it really easy
to meet and develop relation uh
develop relationships with colleagues in
iran and china in particular
and some of my most interesting finds
have come from a chinese student who's
studying at university of tehran
that i met who has access to a lot of
materials that i just
wouldn't otherwise be able to get myself
so most of these things you know like
digitization and virtual conferences
they're not going anywhere um even after
the pandemic is over
they're definitely going to stick around
so you can still take advantage of that
um my time is definitely up so just to
summarize try to think broadly
be flexible in what kinds of sources you
use don't be afraid to open up your
topic and try to you know break
completely new ground because if your
research succeeds in that it'll be that
much more valuable
make good use of digital sources to work
with what you have
uh virtual conferences are a great way
to network and of course reach out to
scholars in your fields who might be
interested in your work
read their work a lot of the ideas that
i came up with for how to
frame my ideas came from reading other
scholars um rheem abu al-fadal
especially i'm very indebted to her work
on foreign relations
um and you know uh talk to them and talk
to your advisor
uh about how to frame your topic you
know senior scholars will often see
things and issues that you might miss
because you're not as deeply
embedded in the field as they are so
thank you very much i hope you guys
enjoyed
my rambling
great thank you so much bill um i've
already started to see a couple of
overlapping themes between your
presentation and michael's presentation
the need to read broadly to network to
reach out to other scholars and to also
just be on the
constant lookout for new digitized
sources which seem to be
proliferating every day um okay so
speaking next will be itsulo
it'sa is currently finishing up her
dissertation at
uc irvine and in the fall she will
become a postdoctoral fellow at the
schwartzman center
at ching hua university in beijing so go
ahead it'san
hey thank you um so good evening
afternoon morning
everyone my name is isa and i am
finishing my dissertation at the
university of california irvine
um so um thanks professor emily baum and
denis ho for organizing this webinar
i'm right at the tail end of grad school
so it feels like a good moment
to be reflecting on the twists and turns
of my research journey
and hopefully it's something that that
will be helpful for grad students who
are just beginning to grapple with
dissertation research
in these challenging circumstances so
i'm going to try to share my screen now
my original project was a study about
the early history of blood transfusion
and blood banking in 20th century china
one of my tentative titles was unnatural
circulations blood transfusion and
banking in modern china
i proposed to track changing medical and
cultural definitions of blood as the
practices of blood transfusion
and then blood banking were introduced
and then gradually normalized across the
20th century
this process started early in the 20th
century when biomedical doctors came up
with tables that you can see
here explaining basic facts about blood
types and transfusion
like people in other places people in
china were initially suspicious and they
were fearful about moving blood between
bodies
but some of the consternation also came
from very culturally specific
understandings of blood as sure and as
something that was connected to
bloodline descent
i had hoped to untangle the uneasy
coexistence
of these multiple definitions of blood
as medical professionals and later
political leaders
called on people to give blood uh
naturalizing
blood donation was a very long process
that stretched beyond the triumph of the
chinese communist party in 1949
in the people's republic of china one of
the key events i was hoping to write
about was a large-scale
government-run blood donation campaign
in the 1960s on the eve of the cultural
revolution
just when there was a rising tide of
consciousness about bloodline theory the
idea that socialist revolutionary
credentials could be passed down through
the bloodline
so that's what i proposed to do
um when i had never tried to get into a
chinese archive or tried to get people
in chinese archives to give me access
to documents about the cultural
revolution which i found out
was not a simple request when i tried to
do these things in 2018 and 2019.
uh the big problem really was the um
post-1949
uh sources when i went to conduct
pre-dissertation research in china
it was obvious that getting access to
documents about things that happened
after 1949 was going to be a very big
problem
for my project when i talked to people
about my work
i got the impression that accessing the
prc documents
especially documents that touched on the
cultural revolution
was going to be very difficult to
impossible
um and and looking back they were they
were really right to
be quite discouraging because when i did
make it into
multiple chinese archives i just
couldn't get access to the sources that
i wanted to read
about blood transfusion and blood
donation in maui's china
um at that point of course i considered
sort of stopping my narrative at 1949
with the dissertation but
ultimately i decided that
the developments in the prc was so
significant and so integral
to telling a full story of how blood
transfusion came to china
that the project would be fundamentally
incomplete if i stopped at 1949.
so given the constraints i returned to
the archives looking for a new topic and
eventually i stumbled
onto units of measurement and
metrological reform
measuring up to modernity uh the title
of my dissertation
tracks how the existence of multiple
systems and
practices of measurement in china came
to be perceived as a problem
by the late 19th century and how the
landing government worked
furiously to design and then enforce a
single system of measurement throughout
china
into the 1930s and the 1940s so
with this topic the arc kind of sits
squarely in the first half of the 20th
century
so i dodged the post 1949 problem
at the archives i found that when i
asked people for records
about metrological reform and
administration they tended to be quite
bemused
and i have had more than one person been
so curious that they had to ask me why i
was reading what i was reading
but the important thing is they always
gave me the files that i asked for
and this was a drastically different
reaction compared to
when i went into archives and asked for
documents related to blood transfusion
and banking in in maori china um in
terms of sources
um like bill i i was i'm very fortunate
that there is a wealth of published
sources
that track official scientific popular
and foreign thinking about the state of
measurement in china
once the 19 government announced the
reform in 1928 and 29
it also published a lot of public
education materials and instructions
about how to use the new system of
measurement
objections to and disputes about the
system were also recorded and published
rather than archival sources so these
are a lot of the periodicals and
newspapers that were published at that
time
and these sources allowed me to examine
the ways in which different groups
responded to the government's insistence
that they all use a single system of
measurement
and in fact i have to say that i had a
lot of fun working with these sources
because there was a
variety of people who were in fact very
invested in measurement and they wrote
very passionately and heatedly about
metrological reform
measurement was also the kind of topic i
could read in the margins of many kinds
of sources for instance it was easy for
me to check the units that people use
when they report
economic information or when newspapers
reported on track and field competitions
so in all i could access a very healthy
pool of published sources which was a
relief because of how tight
archival access had become since i
started grad school and dissertation
research
um but in terms of archives i was able
to work with the collections at the
second historical archives in lansing
and this was really important archive
for me uh because of the topic and
because i was writing about the booming
dance dancing-based regime i faced the
usual challenges that you would face
in a chinese archive you know i couldn't
read certain files that i wanted to read
they wouldn't print certain pages that i
wanted printed but
overall i managed to get a lot of key
sources about um
early internal discussions when
officials were still designing the
system of measurement
in the 1910s and the 1920s and i
also got some really great sources about
the really early days of pushing this
system of measurement through
when they were trying to figure out how
they were going to create the original
standards
and to certify the authenticity and the
accuracy
of the new standards for china's weights
and measures
when my archival researcher was
interrupted by the global pandemic
i also went to two archives in taipei
the national archives and the
guamingtang party archives
at the national archives i was mainly
able to get sources about metrological
standardization when the guamingtan took
the campaign to taiwan after 1945.
so in that strange 1945-49 interregnum
the guamingtang told people in taiwan
that they should abandon japanese units
of measurement and
embrace chinese weights and measures
because they were really chinese
and they were now reunited with the
motherland
um the national archives also had a
wealth of documents about the
difficulties of enforcing
um the new system of measurement in
different parts and different sectors in
taiwan so it really gave me a new case
study
of the difficulties and realities of
enforcing a new system of measurement on
the ground
at the kuomintang archives i found some
records about the early discussions of
metrological reform
but also lots of interesting documents
about other sorts of standardizations
which the quaamingdang tried to carry
out
like getting people to celebrate the new
year on the 1st of january
um looking back at the process i would
say two things to people who find
themselves in the position of doing
research in this particular
source guess era i think it's important
to keep looking especially where it's
possible
of course you have to keep trying to get
archival sources but in the meantime
you really also have to look at what's
publicly accessible to you
personally i've always found it fruitful
to check out like special collections or
the reading rooms dedicated to modern
history
at libraries in china i always find good
public education materials about public
health or popular science from the 1930s
50s or 80s
which are all good jumping off points
for me i would also say that at this
particular time
it it makes a lot of sense to um
to look at the possibilities in taiwan
especially the national archives since
you can search
its database to get a sense of whether
it would make sense for
to for you to go down to taipei in
person to work at this archive
second i would say that um you know you
really have to keep reading with an open
mind
anything you get to read if you can't
get the sources you originally
set out to find find something else and
read that and be prepared to follow any
source
that you find interesting where it may
lead you
the hard truth is that you have to work
with the sources you can get you can't
produce a dissertation resources you
can't get so all the sources you can get
even if they're not about the original
topics you should read them because
you might not write this is the
dissertation you think that you
uh you envision writing but it might be
a really great one
anyway so that's all i have for you
today and hopefully
that's what happened to me in the last
three years and i hope that it's a
source of
hope and comfort to people rather than
dismay
and i look forward to answering your
questions later thank you
thank you so much it'sa and i have to
say just um
selfishly i hope that unnatural
circulations will become your second
book even if it is not your
okay so last but not least is tulia
fraser
julia recently completed a master's
degree in museum and artifact studies at
durham university where she also did her
ba
in archaeology she is currently a
project associate with the university
museum and art gallery
at the university of hong kong so go
ahead julia
thank you for the kind introduction um
today i'm delighted to be talking about
my experience
with my um completing my m.a museum and
artifact studies
at durham university in the uk and i
really wanted to do a topic that was
really personal to my own background
uh looking at basically how the chinese
diasporas were displayed
in british museum spaces but at first
i actually wanted to focus on newcastle
partly because i was based there i was
connected there
and i wanted to evaluate a specific
project called destination tyneside
which was the only museum display that
was permanent
in the uk on the topic of migration and
it was informed by really robust public
participation scheme
so it was really unique and it was
situated in a city that had a long
presence of chinese people
[Music]
so to that end i wanted to firstly
review historically the migration from
hong kong to newcastle
engaging with primary resources
and archives and i wanted to sit in the
gallery
over a course of several months with my
field visits looking at
maybe visitor observation or even
talking to them to see what they're
engaging with and what they're not
and finally i was really keen to talk to
actual members of the chinese community
there
and talk about their life but also talk
about if the museum actually plays a
role
in their sense of belonging or place
making in the area
so i pretty much hit the first hurdle
when the first national lockdown was
imposed in the uk
archives and museums were closed there
was a stay-at-home order
and the hong kong government which is um
hong kong is where i'm from
they issued a recommendation for
students to return and in the end
because of personal reasons i actually
did have to physically relocate
so i was quite stubborn
um i was quite keen to
save as much of the original topic as i
could
and when i realized that archives in
hong kong and the uk were closed
and that the digitized resources weren't
exactly what i needed i pretty much had
to abandon that objective
i still wanted to evaluate um
destination time side
and this was when i looked up ethos
which is a database
compiling the doctoral projects um by
different researchers in the uk
so on ethos i found a project that had
recently been completed only in 2019
and it had amazing field notes about
destination tyneside
so i actually managed to find the
researcher on linkedin and we connected
and she just so kindly provided not just
her field notes but images
and even transcripts of the videos that
were being used in the display
through email i also spoke with the
curator
of destination timeside and she not only
had press images for me she even
physically went down to the gallery for
me to take photos which was just
brilliant
i also had family and colleagues who
kindly offered to visit on my behalf
but the main problem for that was that
there was no projected reopening dates
at
all for museums or archives in the uk
i was still keen to speak to chinese
people and
how they felt about the gallery i tried
to do this
over zoom but
one thing that became apparent was the
age of my target group
i was looking specifically at a wave of
migration that was triggered by the uk
colonial government in hong kong in 60s
encouraging rural populations here to
move over to the uk so
these people at their youngest would
have been at their 50s provided that
they went over there when they were
children and the transition to online
communication has not been gentle for
any of us but especially this target
group
um where people were i think the oldest
person i tried to reach was
nearing her 90s so
my physical location meant that i
couldn't physically go up to talk to
people
and it became quite clear that my
initial strategy to sort of mitigate
my circumstances didn't generate enough
data to support my project
and i had to accept pretty much that the
topic wasn't going to work
and in hindsight i would disagree but in
the moment there was very much a feeling
that i had failed
um and it wasn't nice it wasn't nice at
all
so we started looking at changing topics
and i think
it's a recurring theme amongst the
fellow panelists that we wanted to
remain in a similar ballpark for a topic
um due to personal connection but also
because we've done the research already
so
i basically took a very erratic damage
control sort of approach
um where i identified the biggest
problems of my original topic
and tried to fix it so i widened my
scope to evaluate any displays on
migration in any part of the uk
so i stuck with destination titanside
but i also came across this project
called arrivals
which was um a sort of public led
project by a photographer
just featuring different people who had
recently moved to different parts of the
uk
so not only did i have the researchers
detailed field notes
i also had the curator's photos from
both projects
i also started basically just going
through
ancient websites for hours and hours and
i found press previews
which gave me a different perspective on
the gallery and then i went on even
tripadvisor twitter
and actually started finding the public
reviews on
these displays which was brilliant
because i had now literally different
angles and perspectives of the galleries
so trends started to show up and it
became clear that there was a chance
to talk about the methods in displaying
migration
so i focused especially on temporary
versus permanent displays
um through objects or photographs as
mediums
um i also wanted to talk to anyone who
was involved in displaying migration in
the uk
and i was really fortunate to be able to
contact the curator of destination
timeside and the creator of the arrivals
project
and we actually had brilliant interviews
um but it also meant that
this apart from the varying perspectives
on the gallery i now had first-hand
information
on what the expectations
the ideal project would have been
um like i said quite stubborn still
wanted to interview any chinese visitors
who saw these displays
and it was really challenging because of
lockdown on both sides
um the time difference between the
regions which was sometimes seven hours
or eight hours
and i mentioned briefly the age of the
target group but
soon enough occupation came into play
the uk government
um rolled out a scheme called eat out to
help out which is this
scheme to sort of stimulate the economy
by reopening
eateries and the people that i was
looking at and wanted to work with
were still heavily involved in catering
f b
the import and export of food or even
just running supermarkets
so not only did i have a low
participation rate i actually had a
higher withdrawal rate where people
wanted to help out but understandably
had to focus on their businesses and
were just
so busy i still tried to reach out
through various chinese associations in
the uk
which some of you might know as tong
hang way
i ended up speaking to a very small
number of participants at the end
but not only did they have a wealth of
information about themselves
it turns out that they had actually
talked among themselves
and several people had information they
that they felt would be really important
for me to know
and i really really felt so grateful for
that because
they absolutely did not have to they
really didn't and
while this did not become a core
objective in my final topic
it was actually so crucial in the
discussion of the project findings and
it was actually sort of mentioned in the
feedback of my project as well
so for my final topic i as you know
evaluated the museum representations of
the chinese diasporas in britain
um so firstly i looked at the
expectations
what the curators wanted out of the
project through the interviews
then i looked at what happened in
reality where i
um looked at my one field visit the
different transcripts the different
images
and the different perspectives of what
the gallery actually felt like
and i was really lucky that with the
images it turns out they were
taken between 2013 to 2020 so i had an
additional layer where i could talk
about
how a gallery ages um
through seven years and finally
i had a comparative discussion of how
the chinese diasporas in britain were
actually displayed
and this was supported by members of the
chinese community in britain
and their views on how they felt when
seeing displays literally about
themselves um
changing topics is a really difficult
and personal um decision especially when
it's a topic that's
deeply connected to your background and
we always feel attached to our topics
so no matter how out of control the
circumstances might be there's always
negative feelings when something doesn't
work out
um and another thing that i sort of
misunderstood
in my process of pivoting was that it
was clean cut
that if a doesn't work out you're just
going to jump straight to b but it
wasn't like that for me it was messy
it was erratic gradual and it was so
emotionally challenging
so just to recap the resources i used
ethos
is a database of doctoral projects which
sometimes even includes the data
that the researchers worked with which
is brilliant i engaged some more unique
sources like there's a directory of
chinese associations in the uk
where you could basically see which
person you could contact for
press-related research matters
there's no expectation that institutions
or individuals should help you but i've
learned that it doesn't hurt to contact
them
and i've been fortunate that they have
helped me a lot
but i think it needs to come with an
understanding of your target group
and like i said um for the clarity of my
presentation i've omitted the names but
it really took a village for this
project
to come together and i have all these
people to thank
down to even my sibling who eventually
visited the gallery for me
so i hope that my experience i've been
able to offer some advice
and resources but i also hope that i've
been able to offer
nothing if just emotional solidarity
thank you very much
great thank you so much julia um so we
are going to reconvene for the q
a now if people have questions please
feel free to use the q a button at the
bottom of your screen
i'd also like to invite all of our
panelists to turn their video back
on um so i actually just wanted to start
off with a question
of my own before we get into the
questions that have already been put in
the in the q
a function and my question has to do
with what the the kind of broader
implications
of these research challenges are for
what the future of china studies might
look like and i'm thinking both
temporally and geographically
so it'sa and bill both mentioned that
um you were originally thinking of doing
a project more focused on the prc but
both of you ended up moving
back in time to the late 19th or early
20th century
and so my first question is do you think
it's possible
to study the prc right now and if so
how would you go about doing that
um and then my second question has to do
with just kind of the geographical
boundaries
of thinking about china itself um lee
has talked about the specter of
global china so is it do you think
perhaps the time
to start thinking beyond the bounds of
the nation state and to think about
china in more global or transnational or
diasporic dimensions
and again you know thinking concretely
how do we go about doing that
so those are kind of two separate but
related questions one on the temporal
dimension one on the geographical
dimension
and i just invite um all of you to
go ahead and give your thoughts since
you
are still kind of in the thick of of
doing research or have recently
emerged from writing your your
dissertations or theses so
why don't you go ahead and anyone can
just jump in
i can take a stab at the uh the second
question i definitely agree that
um you don't need to be studying
geographically
what we call china to be studying
chinese history
um in my own experience i found that
it was honestly a lot more informative
for me to look at what was going on
in the chinese communities in the u.s
and see it as a reflection of what was
also going on
in china during that time particularly
around um different campaigns for
different political parties different
governments
it's not like just when they came to the
us um
though those political struggles stopped
um
especially with um the pretty dark
history of
like the u.s treatment towards chinese
immigrants
there was a very strong community and
political organizat
organizing um spirit among amongst them
that
sought to not only influence their u.s
kind of new home
but also events back back in china
um you mentioned me in the first
question so i can at least
try taking a stab at the the first part
of it um you know is it possible to
study the prc
today um i mean it depends on what you
want to look at you know
um it was not possible for me to study
some of the things that i wanted to
study
um from the perspective that i wanted to
study them
i did not stop my dissertation in 1979
though because i ran out of material
it would have been very easy and in fact
i plan to continue for my book project
to go further i
i kind of stopped it there because
that's where so much work had already
been done so i kind of wanted to focus
on
you know what i was doing um but you
know the
there was a plethora of materials um you
know in chinese and iranian newspapers
talking about minor events that you know
aren't normally analyzed you know what i
call
i i like to look at what i call like the
combination of official and
unofficial relations so looking at both
you know kind of cultural and social
connections in tandem with um
high-level political relations and that
i mean there's plenty more to be done
just from the same methods i've been
using looking at newspapers
memoirs travelogues uh there's a great
travelogue that i'm dying to dig into
from
an iran a very popular prominent iranian
author um who went to china in the 1980s
and kind of witnessed you know the
this sort of you know early um changes
that were going on in that period and
writes about them
so i'm really fat you know there's a lot
to be done i think
um especially if you're interested in
perspective of the outside world
on china and the prc and there's a lot
of unexploited sources out there for
that kind of stuff
i think i want to address the the
question on whether it's possible to
study the prc and how
and i think um i i i want to say it's
very difficult
but i want to say that there there are
possibilities for doing for studying the
prc
i think um emily and i uh when we when
we talked about me switching topics
um i did say that we are at the at the
beginning of a great
um have a great flood of dissertations
about republican china
um because it is just easier to get
those sources
but i also feel having gone through this
experience and looking at what's out
there
and looking at the possibilities of
working with what's out there that
i'm not going to abandon the prc and i'm
not going to abandon like blood banking
in maui china
i do think there's a possibility for
looking at those
looking at the prc with what is
published with blood banking for
instance um
one of the one of the people who are who
who one of the foreigners who were
valorized in the prc was um norman
bethune
and the idea of how he had served china
as a doctor and one of the things one of
the tales that's told about him is blood
donation
um so because this is part of like the
government propaganda right this is
or accessible material that would be
kept in a collection at hoover for
instance that kind of thing
so i do think there are inroads to the
prc you just have to kind of work really
hard it's probably harder than it was
you know five years ago but
um there are possibilities out there i
think
yeah um i also want to mention i'm sure
probably a lot of people know this but
um there are a lot of chinese foreign
ministry archive documents
um available online um some of them are
even conveniently translated into
english um i
can i don't know if one of you guys can
remember i'm blanking on the website
that
um i think it's through the hoover
institute though but they're you know
they're documents that were kind of
you know taken or scanned out of foreign
ministry archives before they closed
down and they are
a lifeline to researchers trying to
piece together what's going on right now
and the wilson center as well that was
it the wilson center that's what i was
thinking of thank you that yeah they're
a great source for stuff like that
and it's growing all the time
maybe i can also chime in on the
question of prc history
my name is denise ho and i teach modern
chinese history at yale i'm one of the
co-organizers of the series
um i think maybe uh the way i would
think about
the first part of emily's question is
like with a metaphor and then
with looking at other fields so the
metaphor is just thinking about
like the number of pixels on a screen
and i think when when people
uh look back and they're nostalgic at
kind of a golden age of research in
chinese history maybe that
in the 90s in the early aughts i think
um
people are get very excited about what
they were able to find
and um and the truth is that we're just
not in that situation anymore
so i think that the people on this panel
have pointed to
many of the different ways in which you
can still get enough pixels
to make a picture so that you can still
see an image that describes something
that is
you know a real and true story of
chinese history
it might not have the same grain of
detail or it might require shifting
someone use the the metaphor of the
aperture shifting uh focus
but i think it's still possible i
certainly hope it's still possible
and the second thing that i think is
useful to think about is the way the
social scientists before us
did histories of the prc um but they
were doing
field work with emigrates um maybe in
sort of taking out some of the
methodologies that tulia was describing
or looking at newspapers so i think this
is
done this is not completely
unprecedented
um for us uh and so we should take
inspiration in
from many of these different fields
yeah um that's great insights from
from all of you and again i mean i'd
also just like to offer encouragement in
the sense that there have been so many
more sources that have been digitized
recently and that
are typically accessible through um
university
databases like newspapers like renmin
rabao or
databases like doucho all these things i
mean
a lot of these sources are kind of
mediated in a particular way but all
sources are mediated and there are ways
of still working with them and
developing a fruitful topic um so i'll
turn to one of the questions that was
asked in the q a this comes from
lu huang who asks um that
about the the issue of trying to strike
a good balance
on taking a wide view versus a deep dive
into a specific topic lou is working on
indian and tibetan buddhist philosophy
as well as chinese buddhist history
they're trying to figure out a topic
that can both address their broad
research interests but not be
too broad to be superficial and so do
you have any insights about how to
strike a good balance between
adopting kind of a broad view but also
being able to get into the
the nitty-gritty of the detail of
chinese history or chinese philosophy
that
we're all really passionate about
i can uh go ahead and start just because
i talked a lot about broad topics right
um i think that like you know it's it's
obviously you don't want to go too far
in the opposite direction you don't want
something
um that's too broad you don't want to
try to you know answer an entire field
um you know one thing i was blessed with
was the fact that my field is wide open
so i kind of decide what it was you know
not many people have really done sound
iranian history in this period before
um but you know the approach that i took
was really
um you know it's not like i didn't do
deep dives it's really more that i kind
of broadened my perspective and did
several deep dives on different periods
of history and
and kind of put that together into a
narrative um you know so like my early
chapter is on a very brief
you know 1905 to 1911 moment um you know
where iranian and chinese
constitutionalists are talking to one
another
my second chapter is on uh the 1920s to
the early 1940s
um you know my third chapter takes a
chunk of 1949 to 1959
and in the fourth chapter i do it that
deep dive into iranian maoism that i
wanted to do
um you know so i would say that you know
when you're when you're thinking broadly
you just kind of want to
think about what you can do more um
rather than like you know how can i
you know you don't want to be up in the
stratosphere right you want to have
something in each chapter grounding you
to something more specific that's the
best advice i think i could give on that
does anyone else want to weigh in on the
on that question
um i'll just say i also think your
advisor plays a really important role
in this um i was very fortunate that my
advice and i had
a great communication system set up um
constantly on wechat
chatting with each other um and uh at
times he was just kind of brutally
honest if i was straying from my
question
and really trying to keep me pinned on
um
what i was actually trying to research
um
and not kind of squirreling off in
different directions which are
personally interesting to me but at the
end of the day i needed to write
a cohesive document um that that would
pass defense
um so i see that we're actually getting
some
links in the chat about other types of
sources or databases
we kept the chat open specifically so
that people can share
their advice and their resources with
others but just when you do so
remember to hit the button that says
send chat to panelists and attendees
because otherwise it will just come to
the panelists and the attendees won't
see it but if you have
resources for databases or you know
libraries or
any type of online material that you
think might be interesting for others to
see please feel free to drop it in the
chat we can also
try to compile those and send those out
in a follow-up email to all the
registered participants
um so we got another question
from a librarian asking about
from your perspective how librarians can
make
the best use of their limited resources
and limited staffing so what would you
particularly like to see librarians do
during this time to try to serve as many
people as possible even
with the types of funding and staffing
constraints that they might be facing
what would have been helpful for you and
the in the process of your research
i could take a stab at that um
i am coming from this as someone who's
in museums
so i can sort of relate quite intimately
with the issues of funding
um or rather the lack thereof and i do
agree
um that there is a continuing demand for
more digitization to be done
and in my research project i would have
loved to have
for example shipping logs or immigration
records
um that would have been really really
helpful but at the same time having
worked in museums and during a pandemic
actually i understand also it's in it's
really really difficult
and that funding often relies on
external sources
um especially in the uk which is a
system i'm more familiar with
um so there are a number of documents
that i would have loved to have had or
maybe even just
um maybe like a sort of directory
of the sources that would have been
available as opposed to actual scans of
the resources
that being said i think there is an
element of understanding that needs to
be had
between researchers as well as people
who provide access to research
that it is a difficult time for all of
us that especially with libraries
museums and archives funding is getting
smaller there's more
dispute politically about how to for
example
just make for example colonial documents
available
so i think that there is an element of
understanding to be had here
that we need to be kind pretty much and
be okay that some
documents just won't be available to us
digitally for a while
i can also just jump in and say that
recently i've been fairly frustrated
about not being able to go
to archives or libraries even just in
the region of southern california and
what i've started doing
is reaching out personally to archivists
telling them what my research interests
are identifying um
particular databases or sources that i'm
interested in seeing
and like nine times out of ten i will
get a response from the archivist and
they've been really wonderful
about scanning these materials and
emailing them to me which is fantastic
it doesn't hurt to ask you might not get
a response you might not be able to
acquire all the materials that you're
interested in
but it is certainly going to be more
fruitful than if you just don't ask
at all so why not send an email
denise did you want to jump in as well i
just wanted to throw out a couple of
other resources out there um
the librarian for digital projects at
the fairbank center at harvard
university who's
um has been a supporter of this program
uh bangalore and tongue
is um organizing has been organizing a
series of q a
like um open office hours where a group
of librarians actually get together to
answer questions
um so i think that is a really great
resource um i know that some history
departments the 99 technological
university history department has like
crowdsourced
um a spreadsheet of digital sources so i
think there there's a lot of stuff out
there
um and uh just
as many platforms or not sharing
knowledge about what platforms are out
there
for uh extra um
lists of digitized sources would be very
helpful i think in some cases
there's uh concern about well we can't
publicly share archives for example
because of the rules that
we have to adhere to when we were
originally looking at those archival
materials
but for published sources i think
certainly there are a lot of a lot of
resources out there
i wonder if i can ask the panelists a
question about
how your uh maybe from the point of view
of the advisors and the departments
in what ways could um
were your advisors or departments
helpful
in the process of the research pivot and
in what ways
could they have offered more support
i could go first mainly because i had as
i said quite a
messy sort of transition process between
my topics
um the thing i was most grateful for was
just the amount of patience
that my advisors had for me um
and a lot of advisors are brilliant in
that way and just offering emotional
support and basically letting you just
sound ideas off them again and again and
again
until something works out um
and i think i i struggle sort of asking
for more
from my advisors when considering that i
did my topic in a pandemic
um that being said i think
you know it would have been nice to be
able to connect with
um maybe even more um subject
specialists or if i could be referred to
other people who might know
be more well-versed in the topic that i
knew
but it feels like i was i'm complaining
and what was a really bad situation
so yeah in the course of doing a
dissertation in the pandemic the thing i
was most grateful for was actually just
the support
and the patience and um i ended up
finding
as i mentioned a lot of people
externally who helped me
so the only sort of gripe that i had
i've been able to solve by approaching
individuals myself as well
um yeah i mean i also am very very
thankful for my
my advisor he was fantastic but i think
something
which is more on the departmental side
is just flexibility in terms of
some of the more nitpicky um regulations
that govern
whether it's defense or how to kind of
properly present things
speaking from personal experience a lot
of those hadn't been updated
a year and a half into the pandemic um
so when it came time
for defense uh there was a lot of
scrambling to be done
because um there there wasn't
consideration that we would be doing it
online or digitally or
um all of that and so i think just um i
wish
i had known kind of at the beginning
what that might entail
um but also the departmental level just
really thinking through
the different stages that your students
are going through
and trying to build the infrastructure
for them to succeed
okay i should disclose that one of my
advisors
is um on this is one of the
co-organizers of this webinar
um so i mean i definitely i mean i
agree that um you know talking with your
advisors
is one of the things you have to do when
you decide you're going to
severely veer off the topic that you are
proposed to do for your dissertation
and um i you know my
my advices were very were very
supportive when i told them about you
know the difficulties i was facing
i said look i tried and this is what
happened to me
uh but these are the new sources i found
and this is something that
i think i can work with and i i you know
it was a it was a difficult conversation
because i had to deal with like kind of
the disappointment
of not doing the original topic but also
talking to them about something
completely new that i had
not done before that point um
but you know they were very supportive
and i think i got great feedback on the
topic and especially when i was
writing the early chapters to get
comments on how it was shaping up was
really really um uh
was really really crucial for me because
for me i was like being
i was suddenly embarking on a new topic
wasn't a topic that i had been
thinking about for like years so that
was really really scary and
to to have that kind of support and that
kind of feedback at that formative stage
for my project was
essential i think i wouldn't be so close
to the end now if
if you know i didn't have that support
um and in terms of
um my department i think actually i've
really been thankful for how the
department has been supporting me in
terms of
understanding that grad students would
be like just scattered around the world
and having to do everything digitally
um so i think that uh i've been very
lucky with my department that i've been
supported kind of administratively that
way
as somebody who couldn't go back to the
us and then i'm just completing
from overseas now so yeah
all right well i think we are just about
out of time right at 75 minutes so i
would like to
uh to once again thank our wonderful
panelists for providing their
experiences and
insights i'd like to thank the council
on east asian studies at yale especially
stephanie kim and richard sosa who
provided all the staffing and support
for this event
and of course i would like to thank all
of you for attending um our next webinar
in this series will be on monday july
19th
at 7 30 pm eastern it will be on the
topic of
archives libraries and databases in
taiwan
um please note that you will have to
re-register for that webinar in order to
receive
the link it is not the same link as the
one that we used
for um this webinar you can go to the
yale council on east asian studies page
that
denise has just dropped in the chat and
you can re-register for that
um also just as a heads up the next
webinar will at least partly be
in chinese because we'll be hosting
several archivists and librarians
from taiwan so just as a word of warning
um you will need to speak a little bit
of chinese in order to understand
um but thank you again for tuning in and
hopefully we will see you all again in a
couple of weeks
so take care